[Music]
what to do what to do what to do
what to do indeed
pooh
christopher robin
no
no no no no no
you you can't be here
this can't be happening
stress it's not stress i'm stressed it's
cool so exhausted
evelyn warned me i like to be warmed
warmed
and cozy
i've cracked
i've totally cracked
i don't see any cracks
a few wrinkles maybe
come in here
look
i can't just keep saying hello to people
people can't see you moving and talking
but why because because
you're different
and people don't like things that are
different
so i shouldn't be me no no you you
should always be yourself
no this is very confusing
it may be the hunger you've just eaten
oh that's right
maybe i didn't eat enough look never
mind about that for now just try and be
a less a less exuberant you explore flop
sag oh
[Music]
yes
how about i i know i've got it how about
playing nap time i love play well let's
see it like this
pooh do you think you might be able to
amuse yourself for a while i've got some
rather pressing work to do
house clouds
house
tree
bush
a man
dog
what are you doing oh i'm playing a game
it's called saying what you see well
could you say what you see a little more
quietly
house
grass
trees
headed for the waterfall
i'll be gone soon oh no not the
waterfalls
swim not that anyone will notice swim
swim swim
just have to go with them
don't worry
i'm not
can't change the inevitable
i'll save you
oh yes of course i've grown up haven't i
oh
i've been at my misfortune
just like a hepalop
eo
hello
not a heifer lump
i'm christopher robin
do you remember i used to try and cheer
you up
i don't remember being cheery
hello miss hello can i get you anything
from the trolley um i'd like five cups
of tea please
of course
and some milk and sugar and hormone
honey please
lots of honey
and the game is called say what you see
go first
panic
worry catastrophe speed danger
recklessness
disgrace
shame
humiliation well that's one way to play
it i was pretending that there was a
heffalump but of course it wasn't really
a heckler are you hearing yourself you
need to quit
i think that decision is about to be
made for me stick with me
you worry too much we'll never get to
christopher now maybe we should ask if
anyone's seen a bear or a ticker or a
very small donkey darling these
creatures aren't real don't worry this
is part of the plan
we just need a leap of faith
listen i will call dr cunningham on
monday i think with the right amount of
rest
digger
[Music]
piglet
my plan worked i don't know how i do it
you must be christopher robin's wife
how do you do
my bum hurts hello christopher robin
winnie the pooh speaks a lot of truth
he's got a great philosophy on life
people say nothing is impossible but i
do nothing every day
no poo that's not oh never mind
christopher robin his spokes shouldn't
be on work and work and work it should
actually be on the things that are
important to him not a child anymore i'm
an adult with responsibilities well that
doesn't sound like fun well i think all
the other characters help him to realize
he's living his life in the wrong
direction doing nothing often leads to
the very best to something who
represents living in the moment and
appreciating that life is happening to
you not somewhere else but here
i always get to where i'm going by
walking away from where i have been it's
about something that we could all use a
bit of at the moment slowing things down
and realizing what's important in our
lives who is the great philosopher you
know
[Music]
so we're both in disney's christopher
robin and i thought everyone at home
might like to hear what it was like
making the movie oh that sounds quite
nice
hello everyone christopher robin okay
first question are you anything like
your character like who
like me what was the question again i
was thinking about lunch
[Music]
how would you describe your acting style
well i usually just agree with everyone
on set
also i'm too afraid to say no
i sometimes find it difficult to hone in
on a character's motivation what's your
secret you gotta think like a tigger act
like a tigger and it helps to be a
tigger
right but what if i'm not playing a
tigger oh now that is a predicament
hello eor how do you separate the eeyore
and screen from the eeyore behind the
camera he's a bit cheerier than me
really absolutely he's all laughs
[Music]
moving on oh
before we keep going you wouldn't happen
to have any um honey would you well i'm
sure we could find some
what to do what to do
what to do indeed
pooh
christopher robin everybody knows winnie
the pooh whether you know him from a
millions books or from disney's cartoons
he's really alive as a character in
people's imaginations however did you
recognize me you ever changed a bit
these are the characters that my
generation my parents generation and now
this generation are growing up with
you're the bearer of my father's
drawings winnie the pooh became a dear
friend of mine when walt gave us the
assignment to write songs for the first
winnie the pooh short film and here so
many years later it is very special to
be back in the hundred acre wood well i
didn't expect to be here today disney
are doing a great job of bringing some
of their archive characters to life and
it's exciting to be involved in
christopher robin hello everyone
winnie the pooh comes back to him in a
difficult time in his life christopher
robin always comes to save us now it's
our turn to save him he sort of speaks a
lot of truth pooh it would appear that i
am stuck have you just eaten honey the
whole new generation is being introduced
to this beloved character is something
very exciting hello everyone oh hello
this is a charming story of a man
finding his home again and finding that
inner child
silly old bear it really is a lovely
funny adventure we'll come out the
better for it having seen it i think
come on
[Music]
we've called an emergency meeting this
weekend i promised my wife and daughter
i'd take them away this weekend sir we
need to cut 20 to central you'll promise
these people good jobs and i thought
you'd do anything for this company
i'll have a good time
[Music]
[Music]
what to do what to do what to do
[Music]
what to do indeed
[Music]
who
christopher robin
[Music]
i cracked oh i don't see any cracks
a few wrinkles maybe
i have to stay for work father i never
see you your life is happening now right
in front of you i am sorry
what to do what to do what to do indeed
poo christopher robin
you're here in london
i haven't seen you in years i've lost
all of my friends we need to find them
well hello there are you on an
expedition
oh oh brother
look people can't see you moving and
talking but why just try and be a less
exuberant to you looks puberty to play
nap time i love play well let's see it
like this
well done
[Music]
house
clouds
what are you doing oh please say what
you see could you say what you see a
little more quietly
house
grass
trees
[Music]
christopher robin he's giant oh and he
smells a little funny
[Music]
i'll save you
[Music]
just an average wednesday morning
it's always a sunny day come on let's
bounce
when christopher robin comes to play
silly old bear disney's christopher
robin ready pg get tickets now
[Music]